now more from heart head Italy where the
deadly grip of the corona virus
continues to tighten this morning the
toll from the outbreak has topped 90 100
making it the deadliest country on earth
and just like hospitals in this country
doctors and nurses are trying to save
lives with a minimal amount of resources
Christopher lives say was given rare
access to an ICU units in northern Italy
gasping for every breath these patients
are in the advanced stages of kovat 19
ventilators are keeping them alive but
with barely enough of them to go around
this desperate hospital is trying
something new you can turn a scuba mask
into a ventilator yes we start that
yesterday
doctors are using a 3d printer to modify
the masks so they connect to oxygen it's
a quick fix dr. French is coming out of
the Lycans to wartime triage CBS News
was given rare access inside the
hospital's ICU before entering we suit
it up in our protective gear Cova 19
doesn't just kill people it can kill
hospitals as well and right now this
hospital is fighting for its life killed
in action so far more than 40 doctors
nearly 10 percent of all those infected
in Italy are health care workers Sandro
Rosie the head of this ICU says one of
the Fallen here was a doctor and a
friend can you tell us anything about
your colleague who died it was fantastic
and we we we are still crying Rosie who
practiced medicine in Virginia has a
message for her fellow doctors in the
u.s. is the United States ready for the
Cova 19 outbreak if I have to be honest
know one thing you won't see inside
hospitals our patients families it's too
dangerous
so when patients die they die alone for
CBS this morning Saturday
Christopher lives say Parma